television by the man who made it happen
[Music]
leonard goldenson in your new book
beating the odds warren buffett writes a
forward he starts out by saying i look
at leonard goldenson in marvel
at age 84 he is fit keen-minded and
charged with energy
it almost seems unfair having
accomplished all that he has this man
should appear at least a shade tired the
explanation may be that he's having so
much fun i've never seen leonard other
than upbeat
you agree i agree
i
am
very enthusiastic about being in the
broadcasting field doing what i have
been doing
i'm very enthusiastic about writing the
book
most people at your age
don't have the chance to do what you're
doing what do you think that you did
right in order to be able to be so
active at this age i don't know
all i can say is to be
very happy doing what you're doing is a
lot more important i'd hate to be a
person who didn't enjoy what they're
doing really and working i i couldn't
wait to get to the office in the morning
abc uh obviously everybody knows what
that means um
what was the toughest part about making
what it is today
well the toughest thing was that getting
started
when we acquired abc they had nothing
really they only had their four i mean
five television stations
eight affiliates which covered only 35
percent of the country
nbc and cbs already had 85 percent of
the country
so it was rather difficult as you can
see
to compete it's like time magazine going
in competition with newsweek and not
getting into chicago detroit dallas and
a number of other cities
and
basically
that we had to overcome gradually
uh
if our programs where we did compete in
those 13 markets were very strong then
we tried to preempt some of the programs
away from cbs and nbc stations for that
particular program but that was tough
what were you doing when you acquired
abc
i was ahead of paramount's theaters
united bear mouth theater
we were separated from paramount
pictures under the antitrust laws
and
so i headed the theater group
and the moment we separated see we did
have one television station one of the
first five television stations in the
united states
and i was dedicated to getting into
television
and when i was process of talking to
channel 13
in los angeles and channel 11 in new
york when i heard that ed noble
who was a controlling stockholder of abc
had refused to give any more money to
him he had loaned them five million
dollars
and refused to do any more
and the banks refused to give many money
and i knew that they were about ready to
go into bankruptcy and i got in touch
with that nobody worked out a deal
where did you live in in new york and
what year was it this was
1951. i made the deal in june of 1951.
where'd you grow up
scottdale pennsylvania little town a
little over 5000 people
near pittsburgh over 35 miles southwest
of pittsburgh what took your parents
there what's that what took your parents
there in the first place
my father
was a merchant in this in that town
and
when they married my mother she took her
to scottdale where we were living and
what uh when you grew up where'd you go
school i went to high school in
scottdale
and from there i went to harvard college
and harvard law school how does somebody
get from scottdale pennsylvania to
harvard college
lucky
surprisingly
at our high school you didn't have to
take an examination
why i don't know if you were a certain
i guess certain 10 of the class above
the class
so i never took an examination the whole
four years i was in high school
uh the particular year i graduated
harvard passed a rule that if you
graduated in the top 10 of your class
you didn't have to take an examination
to get into harvard and i qualified for
that
but when i got to harvard
and during football i went out for
football and i thought it was going to
be a lark just like high school and came
to the november exams and i flunked
every one of them
and went on
and uh i was in real trouble
so i made up my mind then and there i
was going to go to work
and
i did that and by the time that
february came along and i passed the
examinations i went back
on the dean's list and was there after
for the whole four years why law school
why law school
i worked in the summer time at moore
leonard lynch in pittsburgh
they largest brokerage firm there and
they handled the melon estate counts
and i used to work there in the
summertime
and mr lynch invited me
when i got out of harvard
to come
into the firm
and i said well i'm not sure i like it
so what i did was i graduated harvard
six months earlier
and went into merlin and lynch for nine
months
and i said to mr lynch
i'm going to determine at the end of
this nine months whether i want to stay
in the business
and i did but i decided i'd rather not
do it and i decided therefore to go back
to law school
and as the once you got out of law
school
then i tried to get into the motion
picture business on my way back from
cambridge to pittsburgh i stopped in new
york and it was the base of the
depression nobody was taking anybody on
and
then i went on to
pittsburgh took my bar exams
but the particular year
that i graduated mr lynch's
brokerage firm had two law firms and the
one he thought i ought to go to had two
judge's son graduating that year from
the university of pittsburgh law school
and i said to my parents i don't mind
competition but this seems pretty tough
and
my mother suggested why don't you go to
new york it's the largest city in the
country
and uh we'll back you which they did
what was it about motion pictures that
interest you
when when i was very when i was young my
father was a merchant but he had an
interest in the motion pic two motion
picture theaters in scottdale
and i used to on saturday
there was no
nothing showing on sunday it was blue
laws in pennsylvania i used to
stand and listen to the people as they
came out of the theater or ask them
questions why they enjoyed it and so i
guess it sort of got in my blood
and then why the transfer to television
and what was it that attracted you in
the first place too basically
when we separated from paramount
pictures under the antitrust laws
on january 1 1950
with my experience with our station in
chicago i felt this was the
communications medium of the future and
i wanted to definitely be in it and
that's when i tried to
buy stations and heard heard that nobody
was in trouble and that's when i went in
but
merged the company into abc why the
title on this book beating the odds
because of the fact that the first place
the bankers had ruled me ruled out they
said they couldn't succeed against nbc
and cbs
the motion picture industry was
absolutely fearful
of television they thought it was going
to drive them out of the business
thirdly
we just didn't have
the distribution necessary to compete
so everybody thought that i was in
trouble and dumant which was the fourth
network was really had a wider
circulation than abc
uh and that's why
from that point on it was a struggle
until we could get it on an equal basis
with nbc and cbs it took almost 20 years
before we got the network and the black
you give credit in the beginning to your
daughter lorraine arbus yes
provided the essential impetus to launch
the project meaning this book yes what
was her impetus she said i know i hear
everybody saying you should write the
book and you're getting along in years
and you want to do it before it's too
late and she and my wife too
and in addition to that to people at abc
and
my problem was
i read paley's book and i read sarnath's
book
and they really were ego trips
and for years they've been after me to
write and i just refused i said i don't
want to go on any ego trip
so i finally hit on the idea
of hiring marvin wolf
as young writer very capable to
interview at least 110 115 people
i worked with
during the years
to build abc
and
he interviewed them all and they are
integrated into the book and i hope
successfully
is abc still on book publishing
yes
did abc publish this book
no no
that would be good
scribblers i i know that you don't own
scrivener's either
how come you didn't take the book to uh
your own company no i wouldn't i
wouldn't do that
i don't want to ever deal with my own
company why is that
just a matter of principle
why did you choose scribner's
um
my
daughter laureen
was friendly with
an agent on the west coast and he
recommended it and i guess i went along
with her recommendation what do you hope
to accomplish with this book
to set a principle
in principle
the steps that we took to build abc the
principles under which we operated
how to build the news department how to
build
communications with the public as far as
entertainment is concerned
and
basically
to really give a true history so the
affiliates and we have 2200 radio
affiliates we have 210 television
affiliates and the people within the
organization approximately 25 000 to
have them have the history of the
development of their company when did
you step down as chief executive officer
of when i worked out the merger with cap
cities which concluded on january 1 19
1986 and what's your relationship with
the company now i'm chairman of the
executive committee
and on the board of course
but i
have nothing to do with the act of
management i didn't want to
because i was approaching 80 years of
age when this merger took place
and i felt it was time to
pass the baton onto somebody else what
does the chairman of the executive
committee do now very little
uh which is what i wanted
i do look at the pilots in the fall for
the fall season
i look at the pilots
on february whatever is going to be
reissued in february
and tom and dan
consult with me from time to time tom
murphy tom murphy and dan burke
they're
president chairman of the board
and they ask my advice and counsel on
various things
and for whatever it's worth they have it
they do what they please naturally and
that's the way it should be when did you
start working on the book two years ago
who's marvin wolf
barbara wolfe was a young
fellow who's written
i think four or five novels he's written
articles in various magazines
and i read what he is what he'd written
and i was impressed that
he could do a good job
and how did you two work together on
this very well he
independent of me i arranged
an h case for him to interview with the
various people i called him in advance
and said i wanted them to say everything
that he asked them to do tell it tell
the truth no matter how it hurts or if
it does hurt
and he did that and i hope they
accomplished it let me jump into the
middle of the book page 272 and the
title of this chapter 15 is network news
senator joseph mccarthy mccarthy of
wisconsin brought his anti-communist
witch hunt to a climax in 1954
with 36 days of hearings into red
influence into the army abc aired all
187 hours of the hearings live from the
moment mccarthy gavel the room to order
to the minute he ended the fort monmouth
new jersey proceedings why did you do
that
well first place abc at that time had
very little in the daytime
nbc and cbs after the covering of the
first day as we did they decided not to
cover thereafter except maybe in little
excerpts in the evening news
i felt
by all means that we should do a public
service over even though we could all
afford to do it
because i
felt that mccarthy in this particular
case was a demagogue and trying to
establish his own principles and i felt
the public ought to decide whether he
was or not and by
covering the hearings uh that could be
accomplished one way or another and it
proved itself
you say in the third paragraph this
exercise in public service cost us
upward of six hundred thousand dollars
that was in 1954. yes any idea what that
would translate into
1991 oh probably
probably six seven eight times that
you say which we could ill afford then
but i felt very strongly as you just
said as i feel right now that mccarthy
was no good
i just want to ask you whether or not
news decisions are made on the basis of
how people feel strongly for and against
something
in other words if if you didn't feel
strongly about this would you have still
covered it
i possibly would have
i felt very strongly however that it's
something that the public should have
the opportunity of hearing and make a
decision as to why
or how he should be handled
how come you didn't keep it up
more hearings continue to do that well
that was the end of the day i mean after
those were over more congressional
hearings after that why wasn't that no i
didn't think it was necessary i think
hearing him on a one-to-one basis with
all the people he had before him i felt
did the job i guess my question was why
you didn't do more hearings of other
issues and other things at that time was
it not cost effective
no i never gave any thought to it i just
felt that this was in and of itself was
the important thing to do
a couple pages later
you say jeff just after kennedy was
elected president in november 1960 i had
a call from senator john pastore he
chaired the senate communications
subcommittee which had oversight of the
broadcasting industry
past story asked me down to washington
and then i'll quote you i know you he
quote him i know you're making some
progress talking to you
and i know you're losing money but i
think you've got to start addressing
yourself to the news problem
why would what was your reaction when
you had a senator chairman of the
communications committee saying that to
you
senator pastore took a real definite
interest in broadcasting it was in its
formative stages really
and he i think he was doing it as a
friend
and he felt that the time had come all
we had up to then was a 15-minute news
with john daly
and john daly ran the news department
besides that
and he said i think you've got to start
really going after it in a competitive
fashion
and i couldn't disagree
up to that time we were losing a lot of
money and i just couldn't afford it but
i felt the time had come even though we
were losing money we had to address
yourself to it
and it was with that i went to see
president eisenhower
and asked him if it had any objection to
my talking to jim haggerty his press
secretary i'll bring him in to head up
our news and he said it would be
perfectly okay
and when the president's term expired
jim haggerty came in
and he started setting it up he brought
in bill lawrence who was white house
correspondent for the new york times
brought in john scali who was a foreign
foreign correspondent howard k smith who
had been an anchor co-anchor at cbs and
brought in other people
and we started
really in a very small way
to establish a news department
after a couple of years
jim haggerty came to me and he said you
know
i really am not an administrator he said
this is going to be establishing a
worldwide organization
he said i think i'm better qualified to
handle
corporate relations rather than the news
and i didn't disagree with him
and it was then we went all out and got
elmer lauer who was really third in
command at nbc news and we brought him
in to head up our news department
and he started to build
a news department for us worldwide
go back to senator pastore he says to
you
when when you came down if you ever are
going to build abc in the eyes of the
senate and the house
in washington generally you're going to
have to build your news operation
why would you care about building abc in
the eyes of the senate and the house
for the one reason
after all
we do not own the public airways the
public owns that
and we as a licensee
are really subject to whatever control
is exercised if it is ever exercised
by the fcc and by the senate in the
house if they are critical of what is
being done i mean the fcc will pay
notice and therefore i think it's
absolutely imperative if you're running
a network you must have a good news
department otherwise you're not really
rendering a public service which you
should
at any point in this process did you
feel the hot breath the government
breathing down your neck no i didn't i
don't think that he was approaching it
from that standpoint is approaching it
as a friend
in trying to help us build a third
network
remember in another book that was
written about william paley one of your
colleagues from the other network
in which during the eisenhower
administration he worked in the
administration for a while
you know we've seen a lot of copy
written over the last few years about
government getting too close to
television and the media and vice versa
did you get a sense i mean back back in
those days this kind of thing wasn't at
all sensitive no i didn't
i
story really approached it in my
judgment as a friend
he said he felt that
they very well could be critical if we
didn't
address yourself to this thing more
seriously and i couldn't quarrel with
that i've always felt that if you're
going to run a network you're going to
have to have an outstanding news
department as a public service
another line on this page johnson
telephoned often
yes
what johnson who what lyndon johnson
what was he telephoning about
if on the air
a reporter would say something
inconsistent what he thought should be
said and call and criticize it
this has been true a lot of presidents
you know you can be very objective in
your approach to the news
but
if you're dealing with a subject that
they're very sensitive about
you're not saying enough in their favor
even though it would lack objectivity by
doing so so naturally you'd get calls
did you you say here last sentence we
never bowed to any president did you
ever do anything that a president asked
you to do when it came to the news
reporting if we were lacking an
objectivity i would but we
checked out our news in every instance
and never found it to be
lacking in objectivity did you ever
think your license were threatened no
never
never concerned you never concerned me
another item in this network news page
or a chapter
but that didn't mean we ignored the news
i had inherited a weekend news
commentary program featuring drew
pearson who was drew pearson
drew pearson was a columnist
operating out of washington jack
anderson i think has now succeeded him
and
basically i felt as a columnist and and
there's this columnist on the air that
he was biased and therefore i was
careful
to say that we shouldn't have him on the
air he said but he had a right-wing
conspiratorial viewpoint did that give
you trouble back in those days yes it
did people call and complain
criticism and properly so have you had
anybody since then that you felt was
biased in any way like that
i don't think so
where if we did have somebody
who was very conservative we tried to
have somebody on the opposite side that
was on the liberal side so that could be
balanced and the public can make a
determination as to the issue involved
you make a statement here on page 282 i
believe that small fact has remained a
secret until now and that small fact had
to do with john scalli
and the fact that you knew something uh
during the cuban missile crisis that you
didn't tell anybody wrote this book and
what was that
basically
uh he had been approached by the k
representative of the kgb actually is
later found out he was ahead of the kgb
in the united states
uh he had approached john scali and said
that
he
was representing kubrick
and that
basically they would be willing to
uh
withdraw the missiles
from cuba
if the united states would agree not to
attack
he brought that to the head of our news
and then turned to me and he said
naturally as a news man
he should report this as a news thing
but in the public interest
if it was a way to try to resolve this
cuban missile crisis
uh i felt very strongly as did our head
of our news we should take him out of
the news department give him a
sabbatical leave until such time as this
thing could be carried out to its full
conclusion
and he did he reported to rusk and the
news department
kept an act of touch with him and with
kennedy
and eventually uh it was resolved and
and kennedy and his people said that was
doing in great part to what john scalli
did
were you uncomfortable knowing that
during that period not uncomfortable in
the sense that we withdrew him as a
as a news reporter for us do you think
that's a good thing for the news i mean
do you think that's something that will
happen more often or should happen i'm
not sure it will happen very often but i
think if there's a public interest
involved
there's nothing more important than uh
carrying out a principle that saves the
country or saves the people from damage
or
harm or whatnot and rather than
judge
jump in to take a
cue
on this particular thing i think you
have to be
very objective and very careful to do
the right thing
somewhere in your book you say that abc
news is number one today yes how do you
explain how it's number one
well
number one it's the ratings
uh
on primetime news we're number one
have been for over a year and a half
uh before that time even in the top 50
markets we were number one for several
years
and so far as
other programs that we have on like ted
koppel on nightline
such as we have in early morning news
good morning america the news
accompanies that
dave brinkley on sunday morning
and i think within the business itself i
think everybody recognizes that abc not
only has top manpower
but is doing an outstanding job and it's
reflected in the ratings what was the
first time you ever did a nightly
newscast
first time first year you ever did a
nightly newscast on abc well we when i
when i acquired abc
john daly had a 15-minute news on it was
on then
every night every night five nights a
week on that week competing against uh
who at that time uh or cronkite and uh
huntley brinkley and how were you how
was abc doing in the ratings
terrible
i don't even know we were in the i don't
think we were in the race at all
that was in the in the mid 50s mid 50s
let me read chap
lying here from page 287
devastating as that day was however the
death of this president
and the astonishing often bizarre events
of the day that followed served to
propel abc news into the modern era of
television journalism
the death of president kennedy why did
it propel abc into the
era of modern television journal well
basically
it was an event that
worldwide
brought the attention of everybody to
this event
we had an affiliate
in dallas a bilo
company
that served
with us to bring to the public the very
best in the way of coverage of the event
and what happened after the event
and i think we
really
handled it with almost i think as well
as cbs and nbc and i think the public
felt so as a result of it
would you say that the gulf war was the
same kind of a
defining moment for cnn i think so
i think there's a distinction between
cnn
and abc and i think it'll be recognized
cnn is a headlined type of nudist and
they did a very effective job and i
think we cover our news a little more in
depth
and i think the public responded to our
news also because we ended up with a
very high rating
what do you worry about cnn
you know replacing the importance of the
three commercial networks i don't really
my own feeling is that cnn is a headline
news type of approach
being on 24 hours a day around the clock
they have to be
whereas we do not have to be on that
type of schedule and can spend more time
on the more important issues
abc
you write this went to a half hour of
evenings in 1967.
there was a period for about a year for
example in the mid 60s
when our evening news wasn't on a single
station in the entire state of ohio
how could you function when you couldn't
i mean what was the reason that none of
the ohio stations would carry your news
because
we had gone from a 15-minute news to a
half-hour news and
the stations make a lot of money in that
dinner time period
and
it took us a while to convince them that
we did have a credible news department
and therefore cincinnati and cleveland
akron and columbus didn't carry our news
but we eventually established
in their minds that we did have a
competitive news and therefore they
started to carry them i want to jump to
uh
one of the people that writes that
marvin wolf interviewed and here was
barbara walters yes
by the way why did you feel it necessary
to pay her a million dollars a year
that's the only way we could get her was
it worth the money yes she's been done
an
admirable job
as an example it was publicized around
the world that she had received a
million dollars a year or more
when she would call sadat of egypt no
problem he reckoned called her the
million dollar
a year girl
she called whoever she called
she got an entree
to them to to
ask him or
do whatever she thought was necessary to
get the news from them did it ever
concern you that this started the whole
business of paying large salaries to
news people
it may have concerned me but
competitively you try to do the best you
can
and
and it's paid off as far as we're
concerned do you think it will continue
forever
no how far up is up i don't know i wish
i could answer it's the same problem
that you have in baseball same thing
football same thing in hollywood as the
program costs i don't know what the up
one of the days that probably will
result will resolve itself when i can't
ask cannot answer she wrote in this uh
or she at least spoke in this uh in your
book here she says after i was hired and
went to the affiliates meeting i made a
big declarative speech on behalf of the
one-hour news
then she says i was practically booed
out of there abc didn't have the guts to
push it through the commitment
evaporated is she talking about you
talking about our whole organization and
the answer to it is uh if the affiliates
wouldn't take the news other than the
half hour and nbc and cbs that were in a
stronger position than we were could
only have a half hour news at dinner
time if they couldn't get it through how
could we because we didn't have the
circulation at that time that they did
why won't uh the networks or will the
networks ever go to one hour news only
if the phyllis will agree to it
how did it work during the gulf
situation when they're there we
preempted and they generally speaking
they carried it because there was
necessarily a serious problem that the
public was aware of and wanted to know
and therefore they allowed it but the
moment
and after three or four days it went
back to a half hour news one of the
other things that struck me as being
interesting because you're such a large
organization today you say here when we
first established the washington bureau
we maintained only three cameras and two
three cameramen
and two sound
men today each network needs between 15
and 20 crews available there then you go
on to talk about you always thought it
was a waste of time manpower money for
all three networks to cover the same
kind of events have you been able to
change that yes
i think they're pooling
certain things now not not with respect
to editorial portion but
where the
where the president is example
has a
comes forward with a press
discussion or press
uh
all three networks should be able to
cover that and really and deliver it to
each respective network and then it can
be picked up by
whoever we want to have it picked up
and it would save money actually
years ago
on elections
uh each of the networks
used to have separate people
uh do a
study as to how the thing was going as
far as election night is concerned
and i went to frank stanton i said frank
why can't we pool who is frank stan he
was the head of cbs president bill paley
was chairman of the board i said why
can't we pool our resources
i said that the public will not be
harmed if we
get
decide to
each take up a certain portion of the
united states feed it into a computer
and everybody have that material
available as to how the election is
going
and then
each company will have its own editorial
person take hold and advise the public
as to how they want to do it
and basically that's the way it's done
except now the ap and up joined it and
the five of us really uh
now in every election we do it in a pool
forum
does abc news make money yes
lots of money
well i don't know what you mean by lots
is it one of the big profit centers for
the network
no but it's it is a profit center what
makes what what's the best thing about
abc news it makes the money is it the
nightline or the nightline does very
well 2020 does very well
good morning america does very well
um
and our
evening news
now does very well so they all are
making money in the book a lot of people
call you a visionary they said you were
way ahead of your time when you got into
abc so i want to ask you about the the
future where is abc news going to be 10
years from now what's going to be
different about it
that is hard for me to answer except one
thing
i think
eventually cable
will have at least 40 to 60 cable
channels
into the home
i think cable is going to become more
like radio
that you're going to have a specific
audience you're going to address
yourself to we have it we have three
cable networks
we have espn which is sports we have
arts and entertainment which caters to
the articulate minority
and we have lifetime which caters to
women
i think
each of these networks of ours and
others will try to select a segment of
the audience that they can concentrate
on as radio does
at the present time
uh in prime time
63 of the homes
are covered by the networks that's down
from 93 percent some years back
i think it's starting to level off as
the amount that will be down and i
estimate possibly 58 percent to 60
percent will be the number of people
tuning into the
networks in prime time
and if that is true
by the year 2000
you will have a 100 million homes as
compared with 89 million right now
and if you get 58 to 60 say 60
would be 60 million homes
it still is going to be the biggest
audience that any media has or ever will
have really and so
i think that the networks will continue
to
go for the mass audience and cable will
go for the selective audience as i view
it you ever see abc getting into an
all-new situation
i mean i know you started you got into
it with the westinghouse yes i'm sorry
that we didn't
but unfortunately i couldn't handle the
losses that would be required at the
time
i just acquired espn which was losing
about 35 40 million dollars
and the news operation was costing about
80 million dollars and between the two
it would be too much of a load to carry
by
ourselves
and i didn't know how long it would take
to turn it into the black
so i had to forego
taking on the new
cnn's news
do you think the abc will ever go back
to that
i don't know i i really cannot answer i
think the time has passed you
when you can get the television
stations i mean the the
different cable owners to take your news
i don't know
there may be alternative things
developing
maybe satellite
you may satellite news in a different
form into the home i don't know
you also talk about conventions
political conventions and you did
something
when did you first start going gavel to
gavel with
conventions we did that originally what
year do you remember
56 60
i'm 56. when did you stop doing that
well we were losing a lot of money
and
getting insofar as the
public is concerned they were not
turning into it
uh and i felt very strongly and i talked
to our news people about it i mean if
the public wasn't interested
in the conventions per se from gavel to
gavel maybe we ought to restrict
ourselves to the key times when the key
people were
on
on the
television area
um
and actually it worked out well
uh
you know
in the political situation today
the political parties
carry three four or five days people
walk all around the circle i mean it's
like the horse and buggy days as far as
the presentation of their issues
the public laughs at it they don't tune
into it
and i don't think i think the political
parties have got to take stock on the
best way to reach the public and they
can't do it the way they're doing it
got any recommendations for them
yes i would say that they ought to limit
themselves to a few days instead of four
days and they should stop carrying on
all the speeches which nobody listens to
and i think they ought to restrict
themselves accordingly
under the team arledge chapter who's
ruined arlington
rune arledge
is a person who graduated columbia
school of journalism
do you want me to give you a background
of him well in other words how'd he come
to abc i'll tell you how
in 1960
i felt we ought to try to go out for
football and we went after the nc2a that
nbc had for years
and we were able to get it
but we didn't have many people to put it
on
so a folder named sharik a nancy
fitzgerald advertising agency
had a small
sports network
and i went to him and i said ed i'd like
to take over your company
and come i want you to come in and
handle our sports which i did
after about a year
so
he came in to me and said that he no
longer wanted to do the sports he wanted
to get into sales and programming for
the network
and i said you're crazy
that's why we acquired you
and he said well i have a young fellow
with me
called
rue knowledge
and i think he can do the job and that's
how we got real knowledge
what impact has he had on abc news
um news or sports news
news fantastic what did he do to to make
it different so that you could become
number one
he has brought in back
people to back up the main principles of
the news
he's been very
creative in anticipating things that are
going to happen so that he has the news
people in the right place at the right
time
and insofar as presentation of the news
is concerned i think that he's handled
that as well as anybody possibly can
you know when the
books are sent out they often send out
publicity sheets with them and i don't
even know if you've seen your publicity
sheet but it's it's so good
that i want to just i want to
it capsulizes some of the things in this
book and i want to ask you i'm just
going to go down the list here i
couldn't do better if i had could yeah
it was issued by charles scribner's sons
and it says it says the book reveals and
it's got a whole bunch of things that
reveals i haven't seen it i just want to
ask you that some of this stuff is
really interesting it's in here but
why a young mike wallace left abc for a
lesser job at cbs
well
john daly as i said was in charge of the
news
and he also was on the 15-minute evening
news
mike wallace took the position
that anything that was good that came
along john daly grabbed it for himself
and then anybody who was a reporter
couldn't have a chance
and so when he said he was going over to
cbs i asked him he said that and i
couldn't blame him he was right but we
weren't ready at that time
to bring in somebody to hit up our news
until i brought in jim hagerty
the book reveals how jerry lewis
embarrassed goldenson on a live network
show
we put him on on a saturday night for
two hours
we kept after him for weeks and weeks to
tell us what format he was going to have
and he kept saying oh it's going to be
great
he came on the air
and he kept referring to me
10 20 15 times during the
program which doesn't mean a thing
i mean he's supposed to entertain
and we became absolutely disgusted the
way he handled himself and after three
weeks and he did badly we pulled him off
how a simple publicity stunt created
frank sinatra's enduring legend and how
after goldenson helped make sinatra rich
the singer insulted him beginning at 25
year feud
frank sinatra bob whiteman who ran our
paramount theater in new york
had gone to new jersey that was at a
little bar or something and he saw frank
sinatra
who was not known at all at that time
and he brought him into the paramount
theater
and when frank sinatra came on bob had
arranged with a group of young kids
and then when he came on some of them
would faint some of them would scream
and so forth and so on
it was picked up by the press
and that's what made frank sinatra
it was carried all over the united
states
when frank after frank
was married to ava gardner
divorced and married and lived in spain
apparently he got tired of standing
around not doing anything and he came
back to the united states
and we went over the river era club in
new jersey
where he was appearing
and
to get him into the paramount theater
for personal appearance
and i said frank
do you have any money
and he said no i don't
i said well
i said capital gains
only cost 25 percent tax wise
income you have to pay 75 for tax
i said maybe i can work out with your
agents something whereby you'll have a
capital gains deal
and have some keeping money
and which i did now at that time
he had come over from spain and appeared
in from here to eternity
we didn't know nor did he know at that
time that he was going to be good
as it later turned out the picture was
released
he received an academy award
and he was impossible
uh
we put on a half hour program
as a result of the deal and i put up
three million dollars in a company that
he was going to own
and he would put in that company as a
collateral
interest that he would have in certain
pictures
if you know the picture business when as
far as a profit on pictures you very
rarely find it
he
sort of kissed off the program
the first night he had bob hope on it
went fine
second night he came in the last minute
went through
i don't know fundamentals of finding out
what it was all about but didn't pay
attention
and within a few weeks it was no good
and we had to pull it off
so i called a blasphemous agent
and said abe
he's kissing this thing off but i said
we want to get our money back
i like to work out a series of specials
for them and i think in that way we can
get our money back and they've said i
agree with you and he arranged for me to
meet him in las vegas that's the sands
hotel
i went out there with tom moore who was
our program man
we were supposed to meet him a certain
time and he didn't show
he sent somebody down and said
he's occupied now but we'll see you
tomorrow
never showed the next day all day
on the third day
this person came down said he's still
tied up
but it never showed
and i
sat down and wrote a long hand letter to
him
i said i cannot understand a man
where helped you get started
and then when you were broke we helped
you get some money
and surprise your concern
and to absolutely
disregard
a date that was set up by your agent i
said as far as i'm concerned i don't
want to have anything more to do with
you
and i had didn't for 25 years
i'm co-chairman
i mean i'm chairman of the united
cerebral palsy
and we usually have a dinner
the night that's going to open
and jack houseman who co-founded it with
me my wife
invited frank sinatra and his wife to
dinner and he was sitting at my table
how long ago
how long ago
about four years ago
and so that evening he was at my table i
was a host
so i went over and i said
frank let's barely bury the hatchet and
we shook hands
but i still never felt warm to him
based on the way he handled himself
back to the publicity release here the
book reveals that goldenson carried
personal messages from the pope to anwar
sadat and menachem began and how peter
jennings got sadat to agree to visit
israel but walter cronkite got the
credit for it
well
in the book
as far as the pope is concerned
after he was named pope
which boat
present pope
uh he wanted to go back to poland his
home
and we had our news department cover him
audio video everywhere he went to his
cronies that he talked to and the
discussions that went on so and so on
and so we had the complete record of his
trip back to poland
and so i made arrangements to meet him
with my wife in
rome
and i presented this to him
and he was so excited about it he said
i'm not going to let this get into the
archives i'm going to keep this in my
bedroom so i can look at it from time to
time
and i said well
i said we're going from here down to
egypt i'm going to see sadat and then
i'm going over to see begin in israel do
you have anything to say that you might
say to them
and he said i hope they can work out
their problem in peace
when i got to
when we got to egypt
we went up to alexandria which is the
summer place
of sadat and he and his wife my wife and
i met
we spent two and a half hours with him
and basically
he indicated he said he was looking
forward to working out a favorable
arrangement with israel he felt israel
could bring to
egypt turn the desert into green fields
such as they had done in israel
and vice versa he said i think we can
make contribution to israel
and basically
he talked as a real statesman
i then went over to israel
to see beggin
and i we spent an hour or two with him
and i said insofar as i'm concerned and
speaking only as a as a company that's
trying to judge a person's steps i think
you're too arbitrary
i think the american public thinks
you're too stubborn
and i said as far as sadat is concerned
he's handling himself like a real
statesman
and i think you ought to address himself
to that problem
it went in one ear and the um out the
other ear
got often
tangent of
his time in poland and things like that
had nothing to do with it
and we left after the said an hour an
hour and a half and his public relations
people followed us out
and said you're absolutely right in
telling him what you did but he said we
we've tried and can't do anything with
him
and so
about three weeks or three four four
weeks later sadat was shot
and that was the end
great statesman
great opportunity
i hated to see it happen
uh the book reveals how golden's and
made a media star out of gold in my air
insofar as gold on my heirs i noticed
when she came to united states
she'd sit down with
punch salzburger at the new york times
and
his uh editorial board or
k
um
here in
kangaram at the
washington post
and i said to myself why should she
limit herself just to the newspaper
so with my wife and daughter i went to
israel
and had an appointment with her at nine
o'clock in the morning
and
she came a few minutes late
said that
she had been tying up
with moisha diane who was trying to
avoid the
bolt the party and she had to keep
everybody together because it was very
fragile as to control
and she said
what is it you want i said well i
noticed when you come to the united
states you sit down either with the new
york times or the washington post why
don't you sit down with all the people i
said i can arrange to have the post as
well as the new york times present i'll
have the magazine people present i'll
have the top broadcasters both radio and
television president and then you're
talking to all the people
she said well let me look at it
and i get a call about
oh
four
five weeks after that
she called and said i'd like to take you
up on that
and that arm building in new york abc
building i had about a hundred people
and invited the people i said i would
they all were present and then i invited
some top officers of some of the
companies like exxon
and she spoke to him and after that
every time she came to new york she'd
call
and i'd have that lunch i offered the
same thing to sadat unfortunately
he was shot and didn't come but he was
ready to do it also
the book reveals
why goldenson went skinny dipping with
lyndon johnson in the white house pool
and how president johnson flaunted a
blind trust arrangement to keep abc's
ncaa football games on his austin tv
station well
as far as lyndon johnson is concerned
when he first ran for congress
carl habesell who was our 50 50 partners
in the state of texas in the theaters
called me and he said leonard there's a
young fellow going to run for the uhf
and i said i can't quarrel with that i
think you should
so they told the uhs station and they
told the vhs station the austin uh hub i
mean johnson station that we were taking
the games away from them i get a call
from lyndon
he said london
you and i have been friends for years
you can't take those football games away
from me
he said you're going to put it on a
little uhf station and they won't have
the people to see it and whatnot
and i said well mr president
our people tell me you're not releasing
any of our product product on your
station they're only getting into the
market through the uhf station
and we feel we ought to support them
he said oh he said i'm sure that's not
true
and i said well mr president i think you
want to look into it
so he calls me back
i said well maybe they haven't been
doing too well with you
but he said i'm going to see to it that
it's taken care of but i have to have
those football games
he said i'm going to have clark clifford
get into this
and
i'll see to it that it's worked out now
here's a man who was critical of the
kennedys with his blind trust and he was
in a blind trust
but he didn't make any difference to him
about our time what do you think of him
what did you think of him overall
here's a politician basically
that's all you want to say that's all i
want to say
this is what the book looks like it's
called beating the odds and the author
of the book
is leonard h goldenson who for lots of
years
operated the abc television networks
thank you very much for joining us
nice being here
[Music]
join us next week on booknotes for a
discussion of american religion and
culture and their effects on national
politics our guest will be richard
brookhiser senior editor at national
review and author of the recent book the
way of the wasp how it made america and
how it can save it so to speak
if you would like a printed transcript
of this week's program send five dollars
to tapewriter incorporated box 885
lincolnshire illinois
60069
[Music]
from the halls of parliament in london
england c-span brings you the british
house of commons and with it common
sense
for an inside look at the proceedings of
england's legislative congress common
sense provides you with an overview of
the powers of parliament and examines
the role of the queen
you'll discover what members do in a
typical day
how a bill becomes a law and the history
of television coverage in the chambers
common sense also gives you a handy
guide to terms of valuable reference
to order your copy send a check or money
order for three dollars to
c-span common sense
400 north capital street suite 650
washington dc20001
[Music]
welcome to c-span's weekly look at the
people and politics of the united
kingdom
this week prime ministers question time
from the british house of commons
question time is a period set aside from
2 30 to 3 30 each afternoon monday
through thursday for government
ministers to answer questions from
members of the house of commons
the last 15 minutes each tuesday and
thursday are reserved for prime minister
john major to answer questions
[Music]
the aftermath of the persian gulf war
continues to be a major source for
questions during question time
however the two main issues that
dominated question time on tuesday were
the poll tax or community charge and
britain's policy toward the development
of the european community
last year the poll tax replaced the
property tax as a source of local
government or council finance
a review of that poll tax became john
major's first priority when he became
prime minister last november
results of the review are expected next
week
on monday prime minister major met with
german chancellor helmut cole in bonn
in a speech there to the ruling
christian democrats he referred to
britain's role in the european community
in terms which most people saw as
contrasting with the sentiments
expressed by margaret thatcher when she
visited the united states last weekend
she warned a future german domination of
the european community
with that background here's prime
minister's question time from tuesday
march 12th
questions to the prime minister question
number one mr john marshall
this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall be having further meetings later
today this evening i hope to have an
audience of her majesty the queen the
marshal mr speaker sir during the course
of his busy day will my right honourable
friend consider the decision of lambeth
council to impose a community charge
more than four times as high as that
imposed in neighbouring wandsworth is my
right honourable friend aware that in
merton where there was a change of
control last year community charge pairs
will pay 50 percent